if I were to go on a naked Space Walk
what would space feel like on my skin
there are no molecules to S to whisk
away your body heat and so you'll be
completely radiative you your body heat
will radiate away from your skin and it
will do it faster than your body can
maintain its temperature now why would
you want to do this naked though because
you know you've all heard what happens
to your ears when it gets very cold out
your ears will freeze and they'll crunch
off like a potato chip well I'm not
worried about my ears oh that's what I'm
saying okay I'm just saying I'm not
worried about my ears
okay
some far more important
just saying
insane just saying